North Korea's government says it has
destroyed its only nuclear weapon
testing site CBS News is the only u.s.
broadcast network there to witness it
North Korean officials brought about two
dozen journalists to the testing area in
the northeast part of the country the
site was shut down earlier this year by
dictator Kim jong-un ahead of a
scheduled summit with President Trump
next month Ben Tracy sent us this report
by phone a short time ago describing
what he saw this morning good morning we
are now on a train having just left
North Korea's main nuclear test site in
far northern North Korea we were on the
site for about nine hours and it was
surreal to see it in person after
reporting on this for so long now the
North Koreans brought a small group of
media there for a very specific purpose
they wanted to show that they were
decommissioning that they were
destroying this nuclear test site so
what they did is they blew up the three
remaining test tunnels at that site they
claimed that two of those tunnels were
still useable that they could have
conducted further tests there but they
put explosives inside and they blew them
up before they did that they actually
opened up the tunnels we were able to
walk right up to them see the explosives
inside and then they removed us to some
viewing stands further away and blew
them up they then told us to walk back
up towards the tunnel to see it in
person to verify that indeed it had been
closed now the problem is were
journalists were not nuclear experts so
there was no one on site no outside
expert there to verify that what North
Korea claims it is done which is closing
its nuclear test site has actually
occurred and we did ask our government
minder if they're going to allow
somebody in to do that and he said he
doesn't think so because they don't feel
that they need somebody else to say that
they've done what they say they have now
done / CBS this morning and Tracy in
North Korea all right Ben Tracy with a
rare eyewitness account from inside
North Korea